You're really mastering division, if you got 3x plus 7. First we think about
what number times 5x, would give us 15x squared, that must be 3x, 3x times 5x is
15x squared, and 3x times negative 4 is negative 12x. Now we subtract this
expression, which changes both of the signs. 15x Squared minus 15x squared is 0,
and 23x plus 12x is 35x, we bring down the negative 28 to continue our long
division. Repeating our process one more time, we want to think about what
number times 5 x gives us 35 x? That should be positive 7. Positive 7 times 5x,
is 35x, and positive 7 times negative 4 is negative 28. We subtract this
expression, which changes both of the signs, this leaves us with a remainder of
0, so our final answer is 3x plus 7.